نحن امام مخيم الراشديه واذا ساهمنا
بالصوره مباشره الى امام المخيم حيث تقف
الان سيارات
الاسعاف المتعدده الانتماءات من
ايضا التي هرعت من عده اماكن في المنطقه
الى باب المخيم باب المخيم حيث جرى انتشار
كثيف للجيش اللبناني اذا اخذنا الصوره
مباشره وان كان ليلا لهذه المنطقه الان
تصدح الماذن على اذان الامساك في داخل
المخيم
بالمقابل المواجهه للمكان الذي نحن نقف به
هنالك حصلت الغارات المعلومات المتقاطعه
من عده روايات ومن عده
مشارب اذا صح التعبير تشير الى
الى غارتين بوقتين منفصلين بحوالي دقيقه
الساعه الرابعه الاولى كانت بثلاثه صواريخ
ثم بعد ذلك بثلاثه صواريخ كنت معك في
بدايه الامر تماما عند الرابعه وكان هنالك
تضارب اما ان يكون قصف مدفعي او غرض ولكن
من خلال المصادر المتعدده تشير الى انه
غارات بالطيران الحربي منه ما قال انه قصف
مدفعي استاذه المنطقه ولكن طبيعه الغارات
التي هزت بها المنطقه على امتداد هذا
الساحل اللبناني من منطقه الناقوره الى
مدينه صور مرورا بالراشيديه الذي هو
امامنا قربنا مخيم الباص هي تدلل على
غارات وعلى صواريخ قويه